[Music]  i want to talk about something it's kind  of serious right now in the pacific  ocean there's a tropical storm that the  weather service has named tropical storm  fabio  yeah they say it's  gathering strength in the pacific  now for those of you in the path of  tropical storm fabio  uh according to the weather channel this  is what you can expect  i will start by hugging you  i will make you wet really wet  i will pound your coast really hard with  my big big waves  over and over  and over  i will come into your port  and rock your boats  all night long  and  i'll destroy your school  [Applause]  what did he say at the end  and i will destroy a school  the sexiest thing fabio's ever said  well that's what i always like at the  end of a sexual encounter is a school  destroyed exactly  he said i committed your ports  i come in and you're rocking your boat